aber wir haben ja mit einem gravierenden
problem zu tun und endlich wird es
angesprochen und ich frage mich auch
wenn ich hier zu hören was haben wie
tief haben wir eigentlich alle auch ein
bisschen selbstkritik in den letzten
jahren geschlafen
mich treibt ihr wirklich um das wir bei
jedem fast jedem sachverhalt den wir in
den letzten wochen sehen sehen wir ein
und dasselbe phänomen deutschland ist
sozusagen eingerüstet ein ein geröstetes
land eine republik was meine ich damit
wir sind jahrzehntelang im sonnenschein
gesurft da gab es ein bisschen ozonloch
da gab es ein bisschen waldsterben oder
wenn irgendwelche auseinandersetzungen
auf anderen erdteilen
das hat unser leben doch eigentlich
nicht maßgeblich beeinflusst und da sind
wir irgendwie eingerostet denn jetzt
seit 2005 10 stichwort migration dann
jetzt pandemie unvorstellbar gewesen
jetzt ist sie da
dann flut und immer immer immer stellen
wir fest dass wir nicht vorbereitet sind
dass uns etwas nicht vorhersehbares so
überwältigt dass weder unsere behörden
noch unsere administration noch unser
moralischer kompass dass man selber
verantwortung übernehmen muss dass man
nicht einfach eine e-mail schreiben kann
an in ein flutgebiet und danach ausgehen
dass vielleicht der chef des deutschen
wetterdienstes oder andere mal den
innenminister anruft und sagt da kommt
eine riesige flut ich habe das gesehen
auf den bildern so was habe ich noch nie
gesehen
nein wir haben eine e mail geschickt
habt ihr nicht gelesen schade jetzt
leute tot oder bei der bei der pandemie
unser in acht für sein lieblingsbeispiel
dass ich dieses dreiste virus am
wochenende verbreitet wo wir doch umso
gesundheitsämter dazu sind ja wir waren
ein jahr nicht in der lage die faxe da
irgendwie in den griff zu kriegen
jetzt sehen wir bei diesen bka zahlen
dass es neue deliktsgruppen gibt die
sich über jahre aufbauen und niemand
schlägt alarm
das wird schon vorbei gehen sowie das
ozonloch oder andere sachen irgendwie
vielleicht vorbei gegangen sind
wir sind irgendwie wir verharren in
einem unzureichenden zustand und jedes
neue ereignis führt uns das vor augen
und jetzt kommt doch die große frage
aber das folgern wir daraus ich will mal
was machen was eigentlich
brisant ist und man eigentlich
macht was ist eigentlich wenn
deutschland angegriffen wird das ist
unvorstellbar ach so das genauso
unvorstellbar wie die pandemie vor zwei
jahren unvorstellbar war es ist genauso
unvorstellbar wie das eine flut ganze
dörfer auslöschten in schutt liegt
genauso unvorstellbar es ist übrigens
genauso unvorstellbar wie das
hunderttausende millionen leute zu uns
wollen unvorstellbar so unvorstellbar
ist es jetzt ob deutschland immer in
einem verteidigungsfall kommt und wie es
unser armee die bundeswehr ausgerüstet
das ist die metapher für alle ist kein
panzer fährt kein pfleger fliegt zum
glück müssen wir nicht mehr in
afghanistan sein damit es nicht auffällt
wir sind auch da wieder nicht
vorbereitet und ich erwarte mir von
einer politik ich kann es noch konkreter
machen von der nächsten bundesregierung
dass sie uns verdammt noch mal auf die
fälle vorbereitet die passieren können
denn jetzt haben wir sie ja erlebt und
da sehe ich eine große verantwortung und
gleichzeitig aber auch eine große
verbündete zeit mir eine große
leichtigkeit sich an der stelle ehrlich
zu machen
da würden ausschuss gegründeten
arbeitsgruppe dann ist die legislatur
vorbei dann kommen die neuen der neue
minister muss sich erst einarbeiten
der neue amtsleiter wird ausgetauscht da
war eine flasche jetzt haben wir einen
neuen der ist auch eine flasche also es
ist sozusagen
es ist sozusagen irre und jetzt kommt
das was mich dabei am meisten
emotionalisiert ich glaube im grunde
haben wir in unseren verwaltungen in
unserer politik in unseren ämtern in
unseren schulen in unserer sozialen gute
engagierte leute aber wir haben
irgendwie ein mail tauschsystem mehltau
so ein mikado ding wer sich zuerst
bewegt geht natürlich auch das risiko
ein dass sozusagen schief läuft der von
mir skizzierte der den innenminister
anruft und sagt da kommt die größte
flutwelle
sie müssen handeln der sieht natürlich
hinter aus wie ein idiot wenn es ein
bisschen regnet und das nimmt
offensichtlich die kraft von den
menschen ihre bürgerliche verantwortung
in ämtern wahrzunehmen
man ist ja nicht amtsträger sondern
bürger und als bürger handelt man
verantwortungsvoll und vorausschauend
und mit herz man sagt nicht die gruppen
vergewaltigungen zehn prozent plus
sondern man sagt dass man wieder 30
frauen die das erdulden mussten ertragen
mussten wie können wir das verhindern
da hat jeder verantwortung und ich
glaube dass das das macht mich schon von
woche zu woche richtig richtig verrückt
dass jede neue fall uns das vor augen
führt und wir wirklich gucken müssen
dass wir uns da nicht fügen es dulden
sondern dass wir jetzt sozusagen aus dem
krieg kommen und das ändern wir sind
bild und wir liefern dir deine news auf
youtube zum nächsten video kommst du
hier
und vergesst bitte nicht unseren kanal
zu abonnieren